[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
look at that
who thinks he's smarter than you why is
he smarter than you
pacman's a loser
alex jones is lying to you that might
come as a shock man
[Music]
jones has fake callers jones has fake
callers
[Music]
elements of bathrooms
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements of bathrooms
ten times
elements of bathrooms
what on earth is going on with trump and
toilets
trump's white house toilet
would be clogged
clogged
[Music]
with documents that donald trump was
flushing down the toilet
[Music]
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
big massive dumpster
elements of bathrooms
ten
[Music]
i love mangoes too nine cents okay
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango aren't measures like
three boxes
that's it
eight or 11 bucks
[Music]
bring my mangoes back down
[Music]
[Music]
the wisconsin crowd identifying with the
mango
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is do
[Music]
all right welcome everybody i was not
planning to cover the gensake press
briefing it was supposed to be two hours
ago but because it's going on let's
listen and then we will get to the news
of the day caring for the uh the safe
care for unaccompanied children should
be a part of what we all want to be
active participants and go thanks jen um
so the justice department today
announced that they are ending the trump
administration's 2018 china initiative
and replacing it with a broader uh
approach towards you know more countries
russia iran north china i know that
justice officials have spoken about this
but if you can elaborate from this
podium the reasoning behind that and
especially in addressing the complaints
of discrimination from asian americans
right i would have to dig further into
this patsy i'd really point you to the
department of justice i'm not sure we
have more to add from here and then uh
just on the global pandemic response can
you confirm the amount of funding that
the administration has requested from
congress we're hearing this number of
five billion dollars that activists say
is not nearly enough to help vaccinate
the world as well as to stop new
variants from um you know attacking the
us as well well i don't well i don't
have any specific numbers we're still in
conversation convalescent
at this point about funding and funding
needs both domestically and
internationally we want to continue to
uh be uh the provider of not just
vaccines but vaccine know-how and
assistance to the global community we
don't believe that you're on the cover
of time magazine again
and we know that in order to continue to
get it under control we need to be
the leader in the world on this effort
but numbers are still being discussed
with the hill so i don't have any more
specifics unfortunately quickly on on
ukraine are you at this point urging
americans to leave russia i know that i
think two days ago the embassy in moscow
is issuing an advisory saying for
americans have evacuation plans that do
not rely on government assistance i'm
urging americans to leave russia to
leave the state department makes those
assessments and recommendations and they
update them regularly so i point you to
them for any updates go ahead thank you
jen um a few on ukraine first uh the
kremlin has vowed counter sanctions in
response to the us we've not seen what
those will look like but it sounds like
the us has quite a bit of intelligence
so i'm wondering if you have any view on
what the nature of those counter
sanctions could be what impact they
could have on consumers and how the
administration could offset that
well we've seen those threats or those
reports but i don't have anything to
provide or assess from here yesterday
president biden said nothing in putin's
lengthy remarks indicated any interest
in pursuing real dialogue on european
security in the year 2022
if that's the case what do you see as
the end game here
well again uh our our hope is that uh
putin will decide to de-escalate uh that
he will feel uh the threat of the
sanctions what the impact will be on the
russian economy on the russian people on
the people who surround him uh they are
meant to have a deterrent impact that he
will feel the weight of being a pariah
in the global community it does not mean
we have never closed the door to
diplomacy and the president didn't have
that intention of conveying that
yesterday either and certainly if it is
an appropriate time he will engage with
president putin again but now is not the
appropriate time or he's continuing to
invade a sovereign country and finally
the administration is working on putting
its budget together how much
humanitarian assistance for ukraine is
the administration prepared to support
it it's a good question what we're going
to and it's hard for me to give you a
number right now because we're going to
continue to assess the needs on the on
the ground and we certainly
are prepared for the potential for there
to be
major humanitarian continued
humanitarian needs on the ground
obviously those existed have existed
since back to 2014
but we want to continue to be the
largest provider of humanitarian
assistance this is something we will
continue to discuss with colleagues in
congress as well thanks jen all right
okay thanks everyone we'll do this again
tomorrow
yes ma'am um wait the board that's what
peter asked sure this is this small
window and in the midst of this window
you have a lot going on with foreign
policy we do means you guys have a lot
going on too all of us yes right how
about that um with that said
how is the president feeling in the
midst of all this as it relates to
this impending
nomination this historic nomination that
he's getting ready to make
and tell me more about what you mean how
is he feeling how's he feeling i mean
he's got all of this going on with
ukraine and russia and then he's got
this historic
uh nomination of the first black woman
to potentially sit on the u.s supreme
court yeah it's history being made in
the midst of looking at sanctions and
other things that are happening overseas
how is he feeling about this he's
feeling good yes i mean i think the
president is looking forward to
announcing a historic eminently
qualified black woman to serve on the
supreme court
he has feels there's tremendous honor in
that he takes the role
that every president has in selecting
and nominating
someone to the supreme court very
seriously that's why he has been
spending time not just studying bios
but also reviewing cases and engaging
very closely with an internal team on
this process but he is very much looking
forward to making this announcement and
getting this individual confirmed how
many nominees has he met with that's
fine i'm not going to get into further
detail on that i expect once he makes an
announcement we'll have more details to
share and lastly yeah the administration
has been fervent fervor and fervent i
against anyone who tries to mar or ruin
the reputation of any of these nominees
yeah what are you willing to do in this
fight to keep their reputations that
they walked into this process with right
that's a good question april i think
what we mean by that is
there are a range of eminently qualified
black women whose names have been out
there as potential nominees
all of these women would make tremendous
additions to the supreme court
and we have also seen efforts to mar
their reputations and what we mean by
that is we are going to
fight back even before obviously the
president has made a decision or made an
announcement against efforts to tar any
of their reputations that means
defending them publicly standing up for
them providing information to
to
you know debunk
any information that's being put out
about them that's inaccurate um and
hopefully uh they all feel that we have
uh we have uh delivered on that promise
but that has been pr important to the
president from the beginning thank you
thank you everyone see you tomorrow or
whatever
whenever okay
there is gensake we were we were not
counting on covering that but it was
just going on so we have a lot of
different things to talk about uh as we
are watching everything very closely a
few very brief housekeeping
announcements first and foremost i am
honored to announce
that
we have now reached
one
million views
on
twitch
very very important announcement one
million views on twitch we did it
we did it and a very special welcome to
all of our viewers on twitch number two
yesterday we experienced
a huge win
in the battle of ideas
we could say in a sense that the force
was with us
as the great actor mark hamill known for
playing luke skywalker in the star wars
series
liked
one of my tweets
a major win some say
the strongest they've seen
um
so just something to look at
just something that we're looking at
very very strongly
uh it was a big loss for the dark side i
would say
uh okay and let me close this tab out in
fact as we go
further and further
into today's stream
um
centauri
says love the show david thank you for
speaking out for ukraine when some in
the u.s are supporting russia yeah i
started my podcast today
with an apology
and i apologized because yesterday
when i
was talking about tucker carlson
essentially defending putin's invasion
of ukraine on the basis that ukraine
isn't quote really a democracy i listed
a bunch of different problems in ukraine
but i didn't actually say
ukraine is a democracy it's a flawed
democracy with problems with rule of law
etc
and so today i started the podcast just
by saying i'm
sorry i'm sorry
ukraine is a democracy
uh it ranks at 60 out of a hundred as a
you know flawed democracy on the freedom
uh i
i sort i cite it in the podcast whereas
russia ranks at 20
and so
the analysis is still the same one
but if i suggested ukraine was not a
democracy and of course it's not really
binary that's why it's ranked out of a
hundred and okay fair enough so that's
on today's uh that's on today's podcast
i want to say a huge thank you to
rebecca metz who just signed up on my
website with the coupon code obama obama
and his new member number one today i
also want to say thank you to tokyo dial
therimo
jen here
margot cabot and odw
for the five twitch prime subscriptions
putting us at six i really appreciate
that
lastly benjamin brown says david sir did
you happen to see majid nawaz
on rogan it is complete madness sir your
wife is up in the air i didn't see that
sir i didn't see that but i will uh i
will check it out okay let's get into
the news it's not exactly calming down
in russia
um us warns ukraine
of full scale russian invasion within 48
hours
okay that's not good
because so far
everything we've worried about has
happened
president joe biden's administration has
informed the ukrainian president of
intelligence assessing that russia
is preparing to conduct a full-scale
invasion of ukraine in the next 48 hours
u.s intelligence officials have revealed
to newsweek
the president of ukraine has been warned
russia will highly likely begin an
invasion within 48 hours additionally
reporting from aircraft observers
indicates russia violated ukrainian
airspace earlier today
flying possible recon aircraft for a
short period over ukraine
a source close to zelinski's government
also confirmed to newsweek that such a
warning was received but noted it was
the third time in a month that keeve was
told to prepare for an imminent
large-scale military action order by
russian president vladimir putin it's
possible for sure
putin can't keep so many troops in the
field much longer
so for now
it doesn't
clearly seem like things are calming
down meanwhile this is from the sun so
you know take it for what it's worth
putin warns hypersonic missiles are
ready and stockpiles blood for war as
ukraine declares a state of emergency
this is also not an indication that
things are calming down
vladimir putin has warned unparalleled
hypersonic missiles are ready for action
troops have also been on the move amid
concerns ukraine's amid concern
ukraine's second largest city kharkiv
could be next in his sights as the
country declares a state of emergency
satellite images showing a buildup of
elements of medical near the ukraine
border elements of bathrooms um tanks
were spotted on roads as russia beefed
up forces in rebel areas
massed russian helicopters in belarus or
belarus as the president biden says
so another indicator
that things are not exactly calming down
and putin's argument for dominating
ukraine foreshadows aggression against
nato
russian president putin's justification
for seizing additional territory from
ukraine signals his long-term desire to
subjugate other central and eastern
european countries
the reasoning putin presented when he
published his demands to nato and to the
u.s earlier this year this reasoning is
signaling that his ambition goes way
beyond ukraine
now
i am confident in saying whatever his
ambitions are in terms of going beyond
ukraine i don't think they're going to
get very far
uh as far as that goes
but
i think there's no doubt that those are
uh ambitions
and uh you know we can take issue with
any one source
but there's really no way to deny that
putin for a long time has been obsessed
with ukraine just as one piece of his
greater
ambitions so we're going to be watching
all of this
i hate all of it
i hate all of it and uh
it's not only for political reasons it's
also i don't like the economic
instability we had another disastrous
stock market day yesterday it looked
like well today things are going to
recover
dow was down another 500 points today
another 500 points nasdag
down almost another 3 percent
call me selfish but that's another
reason i don't want this outrageous
instability
so um
we are
very strongly hoping that things turn
around
um i am tomorrow on the uh
podcast
going to be talking about
what i guess we're calling the alt left
now i want to be really clear here
you know sometimes we talk about the
revolutionary left and when we say
revolutionary left it's sort of like a
less pejorative term for what many of
you call tankies
and
tomorrow i'm going to be addressing the
alt left and i think we need to really
draw a distinction the alt left and the
revolutionary left are two different
things for example i would consider
people like glenn greenwald
tulsi gabbard
matt tybee etc i don't consider them
revolutionary left i consider them alt
left now many of you would say david
they're not really on the left and i
would go yeah maybe that's true so they
might just alt left might not mean
actual left but tomorrow we are going to
be talking about that group
and they have gotten it all wrong on
russia ukraine you know one of the
things i try to do is be careful on the
show with the language that i use so
like for example when people say
uh something about hydroxychloroquine
or ivermectin or whatever
i will never say something like this
doesn't work for covid and it never will
be shown to
i don't know that right so i try to be
careful with my language and say well
there has been no
randomized controlled trial
peer-reviewed on ivermectin that shows
it's effective for treating covin okay
and then
if that changes if a study comes forward
i wasn't wrong at the time i said there
was no such trial
and maybe there will be one now there
hasn't been right so the point here is i
want to try
to be careful with my language and so
when it comes to the russia ukraine
stuff
all along i was reporting to you
here is what the intelligence
assessments are
here's historical context about putin's
ambitions
here's what we know from salad satellite
not salad imagery satellite imagery
although salad i love salad and i would
look at it on a satellite or under a
microscope whatever you want but here
we're talking about satellite imagery
it looks as though it's reasonable to
think putin may be planning to invade
and you had all of these different
people saying
the the the data is false
putin will not invade etc and of course
that's a prediction about the future
and i was careful to say
signs are pointing to the invasion
narrative being quite plausible and then
putin invaded okay
there are these people on what i would
call the alt-left who have insisted all
along putin doesn't really plan to
invade
and if he does it's biden's fault and
biden has a bloodlust and really wants
war
and they've been wrong about every
single one of these things so let's look
at a couple of these examples here's a
tweet from matt taibi who said
i have a long record of being critical
of putin
this troll fantasy that i'm pro-putin
comes from reporting correctly that
russia gate was fake not even going to
deal with that right now and opposing
u.s intervention in ukraine that doesn't
make me pro-putin any more than opposing
the iraq war made me a saddam lover now
of course this is a false dichotomy i
oppose u.s intervention in ukraine
and i recognized that if it looks like a
duck and it smells like a duck and it
sounds like a duck and it has the dna of
a duck and when it reproduces ducks are
born
it might be a duck and so this is one
distortion that that's come up that
he people on the alt left they weren't
ignoring the evidence they're just
against u.s intervention yeah well you
could be both
you could be both here's another example
here's tulsi who said biden harris tell
us we must bear the cost to defend
freedom in ukraine but while you and
your family struggle with higher prices
the power elite capitalized almost like
a trumpian tweet won't suffer at all and
if the conflict goes nuclear
nuclear
they'll be safe in cushy massive bunkers
while you and your loved ones fry again
alluding to this
war lust supposedly from joe biden who
told us very clearly
we're not putting troops on the ground
we're not doing that now are we fighting
a proxy war
by funding ukraine i talked yes of
course of course i talked about that but
this idea that biden's desperate for war
bloodthirsty and it might come on guys
and then here's glenn greenwald glenn
greenwald he has one story that he likes
to tell
when whenever war emerges there is an
intense surge of nationalism in the u.s
people across the spectrum unify the
media speaks an almost total lockstep so
i'm sure polls will indicate approval
for now but i really wonder how much
americans are willing to sacrifice for
ukraine
there was no evidence that biden wanted
war in ukraine and planned to get
involved with troops or whatever
um
uh hold on a second
i do have to ban someone here i'm sorry
guys
okay
uh so anyway they've all been playing up
the bloodthirsty biden narrative all
along and like it's just not being born
out biden's not even really putting in
very serious sanctions yet and that's
okay i think he needs to keep something
in case putin does go towards kharkiv or
kiev um
but you know
this this bloodthirsty biden meme is
really just just pathetic so we're gonna
deal with that that'll be my critique of
the alt left
tomorrow on the podcast and i hope all
of you
uh check it out because i think it's
going to be
quite interesting i don't know what this
is we're going to close that up
but we'll continue continuing to monitor
other things
um the four show flip asks via super
chat do you think russia's actions if
not sufficiently addressed
internationally will set a precedent
china might use to justify action in
taiwan yeah i mentioned that uh two days
ago absolutely
yep i think china's paying
very close attention to what's going on
and uh
they have um they have some some pretty
serious ambitions
when it comes to taiwan i'm being told
that our twitch
uh oh i see our go live message was
messed up on twitch got it i just
updated it thank you and welcome i want
to say a big thank you to
um
oh to no one i have no one to thank okay
that's okay we're gonna we're gonna
continue going all right next thing the
stream schedule for the next few days
now this may be completely upended
because
intelligence is now warning about a
full-scale invasion of ukraine in the
next 48 hours so this may change but as
of right now here's what we have
scheduled okay
tomorrow 3 45 these are all eastern
times these uh streams are all scheduled
on youtube you can um set a reminder on
on there now tomorrow at 3 45 pm eastern
we will start with day one of cpac we
will carry kimberly guilfoyle's speech
oh hold on do i have her uh
the best is yet to come
oh i don't think i have that i really
should get that
i really should get that right come on
yeah now we're going to go ahead and get
that we're going to first listen to the
kimberly guilfoyle speak tomorrow come
on david right yep and then we'll be
covering ted cruz
and then we will continue coverage into
the evening tomorrow
okay so then friday
we will be starting at 1 30 p.m eastern
right
and we will be this is my hype board by
the way
diamond and silk are helping me we will
have candace owens
and hold on who else are we gonna have
oh nigel farage and ben carson so
candace owens nigel farage and ben
carson friday starting at 1 30.
and then saturday
we will carry the donald trump keynote
to cpac we will be starting at 6 15 p.m
eastern time um
and going until whenever that ends i
have made the decision not to cover cpac
on sunday come on okay and uh the reason
why is it's kind of like a trash
throwaway day it starts at like 9 00 a.m
i don't think many people are gonna tune
in at nine a.m eastern you know the sun
will just be coming up on the west coast
and
it just doesn't make sense so sunday
there will be no cpac stream
and then a tuesday
and you can already regis pre-register
for this we will be live with joe
biden's state of the union that will be
tuesday starting at 8 p.m eastern the
speech itself scheduled for 9 00 p.m
eastern okay so that's the stream
schedule
for the next few days
we have taken care of that
uh okay
thanks to lonerbox for the raid not a
channel i'm familiar with but welcome to
everybody watching from the loner box
also want to say thank you to rabid
diabetic for the twitch prime
subscription and i want to invite all of
you every
single last one of you
to sign up on my website joinpakman.com
it's the best way to support all of the
streams essentially daily streams all
week and into next week almost almost
daily streams and you can use the coupon
code right above my head obama
to get a pretty serious discount off of
the price of a membership classy andy
says bedan may not have troops on the
ground in ukraine but he does have them
in poland and lithuania want them too
yes
uh yes and we have talked about that
justin says putin's terms
were no nato expansion nato for years
broke their own promises not to expand
and continue to expand case in point the
u.s keeps saying no to putin terms why
isn't this being discussed because it's
false
because it's false justin you've got to
read the history of the negotiations
around the expansion promises there was
a verbal
uh
discussion of no eastward expansion and
no ukraine and nato
it was removed before anything was
signed and codified
okay so that's why
nato never actually
it's sort of like if you go and you talk
to a car dealer right and you're out in
the lot and you go okay this uh this
this po dunk jalopy what's this thing
cost and they say oh this thing's eight
grand and you go eight grand i like that
let's go inside and sign papers great
and then they come to you and they go
you know it's actually 10 grand here's
the paper and it says 10 grand and you
look at the paper and it says 10 grand
and then you sign it
you can't later go
you agreed to 8 grand it's like no no
then we changed it to 10
and put it in writing
and you signed it
okay that's what happened with the
eastward expansion so i i don't know
how many more times i have to uh mention
that
probably more probably more uh would be
my guess
um matt says does the right donate more
because they have more people especially
lower and middle class who don't
understand that they should be saving
money for their expenses instead of
donating
uh i don't know i don't know that's an
interesting question matt that's a very
interesting question
justin's fair point i'll look more into
it thanks david beautiful thank you
justin appreciate that
also when nato expands they're not
invasions russia's invading ukraine i
think that's a beautiful point
uh
from uh from a twitch uh a twitch views
viewer okay good
let's keep going a few little things to
go over with you guys here is a very
ugly situation this woman
i don't know if her name is really karen
or if that's the sort of racialized term
that's being used for
the the title of this video is karen
doesn't want taco people in her
neighborhood and refuses to let them set
up
i love tacos and i love food carts why
anyone would want to prevent
in small towns and small cities around
the entire country
people are desperate for the cultural
and culinary elements of a taco truck
and this woman doesn't want tacos look
at this
not in our neighborhood it's like
they're you think they're setting up a
you know uh uh
a subsidiary of nambla it's like this
it's tacos lady
it doesn't belong to you
little girl you pushed
imagine fighting against tacos
and you're on video and you did
sweetheart
don't talk
god these people aren't spanish spanish
means from spain that's another pet
peeve of mine are you spanish like well
hold on whoa
so spain's a country in europe do you
even know what you're asking me
i would bet anything these are not
spanish people she may love spanish
people that's not who's here
there's no tacos in spain
and from the accents i'm hearing of
people speaking spanish i don't hear a
single spanish accent there well tony i
have the people around me who live with
me for 10 years and they know how dearly
i appreciate spanish people she really
appreciate
it would be great if someone said to her
why are you talking about spanish people
there's no spanish people here
what's your obsession with spanish
people we're like family in this
neighborhood
i'm from this neighborhood
guys i love spanish i love that
now she switches to latino okay i have
no issue with you
it's nothing against you personally
it has nothing to do with your
personality it's it's about you wanting
to feed your family i want to keep my
family
is she saying the tacos make her family
unsafe
it's not it's i could understand
thinking a quesadilla might endanger
children but tacos are so so benign
wouldn't it be safer if they set up a
taco place and tons of people were
around like if the problem is the place
is dangerous
for reasons other than the tacos
you would think the activity of a taco
truck or taco stand would would make it
safer
you're standing right in front of the
homes here
is
does anybody know what she's talking
about
my dear i hear that you don't care about
neighborhoods i hear you i never said
you don't live here that's why you don't
know what's in my mouth
nothing here for me then you guys are if
i cannot walk around with my child in
the neighborhood
i i just don't understand even the
connection here
um let's see if there's an article
or any any commentary about what what is
even going on
her reasoning is the taco stand makes
the name neighborhood dangerous yeah i
don't even get it and she keeps talking
about spanish people very very ignorant
woman needless to say okay very good so
that's that
um
oh hold on a second here
okay now everything's fine okay so we
got that here's another one this is a
really good one this woman ruth swanson
is a republican congressional candidate
as soon as you hear her speak you
probably don't need me to tell you that
she's a republican she was interviewed
and this is really good
she was asked for any evidence of any
fraud in the 2020 presidential election
and she didn't want to present it today
she just she just didn't want to
not today guys
trump um who got the most votes in the
2020 election trump
um
why do you think that uh that bill barr
found no evidence of a voter fraud
i think that they should have gone and
taken what the evidence was in arizona
across the nation they should have done
their due diligence with this and i
don't think that they did and
what was the evidence
um
[Music]
there were multiple testimonies of
people who were complaining about lots
of different things but i i don't think
i want to go into it all today yep not
today's not a good day for her to go
into that other days she would give you
all the evidence just not today
okay any any specifics of the evidence
that you did you want to say no not
today not today thank you
yeah just one thing so we'd have a sound
bite so you could say said that trump
won and just like one bit of evidence
not today no thank you
not today guys you are not going to get
that evidence today um she apparently
from the mike pillow school of thought
where she will be getting that uh
information out to us
within the next couple of weeks it's
going to come out
tor 09 mt says david are you familiar
with live liveuamap.com
seems like a useful tool for dissecting
military situations yeah i am familiar
with it
uh let's pull it up real quick
just to show people
what it looks like
it's quite an interesting uh quite an
interesting tool
and so of course we can zoom in over
here
and we can get a sense
as to
what is going on
um i don't know that i'm the right
person to really dissect this
but let's see what these elements are
of ceasefire violations okay yeah so
they're keeping an eye it is a very
interesting tool i don't know that it
would really give us insights that are
not in what's being reported in in
textual news articles but it is an
interesting site let's see what this
randomly is
kharkiv airport closed oh i see okay
these are all ceasefire violations
there's a rally tonight
global okay yeah so it's it's an
interesting website
interesting website i encourage people
to uh to take a look at that uh other
super chats coming in new coupon code
should be dangerous tacos 22. i agree
gabe says i think she had that evidence
in giuliani's bedroom or no in his in
his den
yes
that is exactly where the evidence is
okay here's another really interesting
story this is so weird as many of you
know alex jones is banned from spotify
and he's streaming on spotify it just i
i don't know it doesn't really make
sense the alex jones show
is streaming on spotify
infowars the alex jones show is
streaming on spotify even though spotify
banned all content from alex jones in
2018.
what
full-length episodes of the alex jones
show have been uploaded daily on spotify
since february 20th and remain
undetected by the platform's moderators
the alex jones show is the first result
that appears when searching infowars on
spotify
this oversight speaks to a larger
problem of spotify's shoddy enforcement
of its own rules yeah
so that's going on and that's very very
strange
here's something else i'm going to
present to you this is video from
russian television so i'm going to tell
you what this allegedly is and then
we'll watch it together and we will
assess it and i think we will only be
giving our opinions we won't be saying
what this really is
this is video from russian television
purporting to be
ukraine
shelling members of the media and many
of you who wrote to me about this said
david
it looks completely staged let's take a
look at it together and see what we make
of it
[Music]
okay
so i i don't know honestly like i'm not
even gonna assess it because i have no
idea
this is purportedly the shelling of
journalists by ukraine from russian
television
many people saying
to me
it is completely
unconvincing
let's look at it once more
it's also weird how it's being filmed i
i don't know i have no idea
okay
i don't know i i so i'm i'm being
careful i do not know if that is real or
not
it is very very difficult for me to tell
um okay but actually before we get to
that before we get to that
let me do
a couple other voicemails oh thank you
to the one stein and rich
for signing up via twitch prime numbers
eight and nine today
i very much appreciate that
um
and i welcome anybody okay yeah i'll do
a free item whoever is the next member
on my website meaning number 10
i'll give you a free item from my online
store we've got hoodies we've got
sweatshirts t-shirts coffee mugs hats
better hats than this one that's for
sure
whoever is the next person to sign up on
my website joinpakman.com
even if you use a discount code i will
send you a free item and you can use the
coupon code obama for a discount
you can also use the coupon code uh
please don't war please don't war if you
would like
other super chats david what is going on
just got up to speed how do you turn it
around if the crazy trumpers eat up fox
pro-russia stuff too
we're really up against it
we're really up against it
deretin says i was a forward artillery
observer in british forces this is not
an artillery shell landing guaranteed
all right there is one
one perspective
a thank you to uh dat side for the
twitch prime subscription remember the
the offer was for the next website
member so that is still open it looks
like there's six people racing to sign
up right now we'll see who gets in there
first uh let's do a couple of voicemails
yes i have 1100 voicemails for you i'm
not going to play all of them but let's
listen to a few here is one whitney hit
us with your next uh idea
so my hypothesis
is that um
the
german and italian like combination um
like the family that has like the nazis
there's like the
cool looking like interesting noses or
something like that yes german italian
noses are fascinating according to
whitney uh here's troy york
uh first of all your assumption that all
democrats must think a certain way
is fascistic
is illogical
i have never said all democrats must
think a certain way back to whitney
so i think if they made like another
superpower that was like
mainly russian
or like you know maybe somewhere
more up north
they'd probably have more success i bet
like if they all like
i've gotten a series of one two three
four five six i have seven back-to-back
voicemails from jimmy from philly who i
haven't heard from in a really long time
do we wanna listen to that
do we wanna see what what sort of
screeds he's delivered thanks to mundy
man and gw jumpman for the twitch prime
subscriptions i'll tell you who's
getting the free uh
clothing item momentarily seems people
want to see what jimmy's up to let's see
if he's having another medical event
what is this [ __ ]
dude non-stop nonsense from you dude
when are you gonna [ __ ] tell the
truth
i figured out your audience is mostly 15
to 20 year olds
no we have the demo demographic data the
bulk of our audience is 25 to 45.
that's where we've got like the
plurality of the audience great job
there david
jesus christ
sounds [ __ ] believable
i hope
kyle's lawyers
or i hope conservative lawyers in
general just keep filing cases against
you david i i hope they bury you
i hope they bury you
what is he talking about then he called
right back
david jimmy from philly what
so i'm watching this
this nonsense this this soyboy you got
on the phone
with that
the national popular vote yeah i've been
following that for a while
even if they get to all the states it
doesn't matter david it's never gonna
[ __ ] pass
keep jimmy doesn't seem to understand
how that works okay next voicemail david
jimmy from philly
what
nine dollars in super chats and you
don't [ __ ] read
them i don't know what he's talking
about he called right back david jimmy
from philly what
so
so i'm i'm watching you on discord and
like like she ignored me on discord
which i will never do again what is he
even what what is he talking about what
i ignored him on discord but i guess
it's
i guess it's more entertaining to talk
to these little silly boys
who try to act like they're [ __ ]
smart whether they're like
19 david that's most of your audience
what 15 to 20 years old like i said the
the plurality of our audience is 25 to
45.
david jimmy from philly what
so i hear you talking this nonsense
about facebook listen to me david you're
you're you're in league with all these
[ __ ] when did i talk about
baseball does anybody remember when
baseball was something i said
baseball
i don't even remember what that was
about
facebook he said i thought he said
baseball
let's listen again finish nonsense about
baseball
no he's saying baseball right
you guys think he's saying face i think
it's baseball let's listen to it one
more time david give me from philly what
so i hear you talking this nonsense
about facebook
oh maybe he's i think he says base book
base book i don't know what it is hey
david you're you're you're in league
with all these [ __ ]
see you can't tell the truth ain't no
money in the truth really that's what
you figured out
i guess that comes along with being
jewish huh ooh and jimmy going
anti-semitic there
uh is anybody shocked that jimmy
harbor's anti-semitic beliefs is that
surprising to i'm so surprised guys
david get me from philly fight
so i hear you talking all this [ __ ]
nonsense
you're talking to this spanish guy right
i don't remember anybody from spain
calling in jimmy now
speaking of which that that trope rears
its ugly head again
oh wait no a guy from spain did call in
like a while ago
is jimmy even does jimmy know that or
who who the hell knows i don't even know
what jimmy knows obviously [ __ ]
right
let me join you a little clue david
west african comes here right he says to
me
what the [ __ ] is wrong with black people
over here
okay all right we're getting we're gonna
get away from that and here's the last
one from jimmy
david give me some filling
why david pacman power
would you guys be shocked to know
that uh jimmy from philly
is actually a regional director for bain
capital consulting would that surprise
you guys that he's doing high level very
very high level management consulting
uh i'm kidding
i'm kidding obviously
so that's
that's jimmy
uh no he
some people thought i was serious no no
no
i want to say thank you to derek edgar
who gets a free item from my online
store along with being new member number
13 today on my website also a huge thank
you
to dwayne robertson
wesley mclaughlin and matt baker all of
whom just signed up on my website
joinpacman.com with the coupon code
obama
that's the wrong one sorry with the
coupon code obama obama there we go
wrong drop also thanks to blueberry babe
for gifting two subscriptions
very very much
appreciate that as well okay a couple of
other voicemail screeds
uh back to whitney
hi david it's whitney hi um so i was
driving down the road
and this is lancaster california
and there's this lady here
and she's holding a sign that says she
can't afford surgery
like her kids or
i think it's maybe her mom or something
it was really hard to understand her
she's from a different country well
that's very sad i couldn't afford
surgery
and i'm like
well
how is it that this country
can afford to pay for transgenders and
we're off of whitney on that note let's
go next to eric from mass
hey david it's eric from math i've been
thinking about this i'm thinking about
how to dumb this down for you please and
here's the best way i can do it eric i
really need you to use the simplest
possible language when you explain your
theories to me free doses for eight
billion people would be 24 billion doses
it would take 32 years to make them if
you had five different plants
making one
kills per second it would take 10 years
can you explain that to me
i could i definitely cannot explain that
to eric in the f when they run in seven
months
and seven months i mean
uh okay
uh david pakman i have signed up to
donald trump's social media site
the truth and conservatives and
republicans need to continue to embrace
man troy york is really boring he's
barely audible
so i realized i made a huge mistake
because i was researching about india
and um i realized that the middle east
went over first and enslaved the indians
right
um dave have you seen the faked russian
video of a guy who quote lost his leg
but he still had his prosthetic leg
attached in the video i didn't see that
and i'm not going to look it up i'm not
going to look it up
you're a little shit-stained
runt [ __ ]
you need to have a big
[ __ ] stuck in your mouth okay and we're
gonna get away is it why is it that the
right-wing callers
can't make a substantive critique of me
without either
saying i'm a liar propagandist funded by
george soros
saying something homophobic saying
something anti-semitic like why can't
they say hey david you know what you're
wrong about your view on taxes and
here's why
princeton found
in a 1997 study
that the optimal tax rate it like
it's always this insanity they they just
they have no other way to communicate
seemingly it's it's really sad really
really sad and it's it but it doesn't
bode well for the country
i think it's important to mention
uh one other super chat here bay photo
says tacos from
mexico mexico exactly all right let's
get into a very very strange story i
think you guys are going to like this
one republican house candidate martin
hyde who is all about the police all
about back the blue
is caught threatening a police officer
during a traffic stop with one of these
do you know who i am moments
let's take a look at the video
and this is a supporter of the police
guys remember
hey how are you doing how are you doing
sarah sebastian sarah's at the
on audio and video recording the reason
for the stop you were observed this was
uh last week going 57 and a 40 and you
were on your phone texting while you
were doing that
that was at euclid by the way these
people with the phones
they are a
existential danger
i i have become skilled
at spotting people on their phones
from a mile away on the highway if you
go down a street if i'm if i'm in a
straight stretch of highway by the way
do you guys know how to use highways
because a lot of people in this country
seem to have no idea
how a highway works
you stay to the right until such time
that you need to pass guys please
if i'm going in the right most lane that
i can because i understand how the way
the way you're supposed to use a highway
and i see someone a mile ahead
in the fast lane with a line of cars
behind them they don't even realize
they're not using the highway correctly
and they're slowing everybody down
i can immediately tell they're on their
phone
and of course you're not really supposed
to pass on the right if you understand
how to hide how to use a highway
you're not supposed to pass on the right
but at a certain point you have no
choice
because they're going
64 in a 65 in the fastest lane
so you pass them on the right
and then they're like this this is the
holding this is this is the way there
you see you go by like this
it's a danger out there
every single one needs to get a ticket
okay they got to be dealt with in this
exact way
please learn to use a highway don't get
off the phone god
by the way we'll start this over in a
second one thing i fantasize about when
i see these people
is
i fantasize about installing in my car
a message like a uh
like an led thing where i can type
something and it'll display the message
and i fantasize about flipping a switch
and it displaying get off your phone
getting right in front of them and
slowing down until they see they get off
your phone message
um i fantasize about that
a lot of people
identifying with that okay let's take it
from the top and and by the way speeding
allegedly while texting get this guy off
the road
hey how are you doing are you doing
sorry i've said asking sarasota police
department you're on audio and video
recording the reason for the stop you
were observed going 57 and 40 and you
were on your phone texting while you
were doing that
that was at euclid and fruit bomb
i'm not pointing at you i'm pointing in
the direction where it was just
go right ahead sir can i see you like
that yes sir i do can i show you like
did you guys catch that you know who i
am right
you know who i am right
uh what
and on that basis what why are you
bringing that up sir do you does that do
you think that you should be exempt from
the law
um
by the way a1 andy says david are you
going on the patrick bet david podcast
they need a progressive
uh i've been invited i'm trying to
figure out when i can get down to
florida in order to do it
but i'm looking at that very very
strongly i was just in touch with
patrick bett david's producer today
uh let me see actually if i've heard
back
no i haven't no i'm trying to yeah
they've invited me and i i gotta get
down there let's continue registration
insurance please did you do this
yes sir
you see that you're gonna do this
yes and it's on camera
i'm sorry big mistake
i still have a job to do sir
yeah for now
yeah for now
this this guy is just trash
off sebastian it's going to be on the
citation can i see your insurance
registration on the side which you will
be getting momentarily there's not going
to be a verbal warning here
can i see your registration please
you're not going to give me a
registration sir can you harass me
i'm asking you if you're going to
produce me with your registration
you want to have it on you
go
tell him how would you just mean to me
okay sir are you if you want to produce
your registration
i'm asking you if you have your
registration you're making career
decisions
this is a career decision verifying that
this guy is legal illegal to drive this
car and whether it's insured you could
lose your job over that you know who i
am
sorry because you were speeding and you
were texting
says who
here's part two
um the guy claims to have called the
officer supervisor by the way this guy's
running on backing the blue
is that surprising to anybody this guy
supports our police
yeah
call the supervisor
i just spoke to you
okay
did he just say is your russian
immigrant status what makes it making
you behave is that what he said
what did you guys hear that
it's the wind noise makes it very tough
let's try a gun here
you want trailer before anymore is it
your russian immigrant status that makes
people like us
yeah
he said is it your russian immigrant
status that makes you
something people like this something did
was it treat people like this
we'll see who goes
like
this we have so many criticisms of
things that police officers sometimes do
this officer
saw someone going
50 faster than the speed limit and
texting
and pulled them over
recognized the person and is still doing
her job
and she's the problem and he backs the
blue
you don't want your paper
sir you're going to be issued a citation
anything you have to say
away from the supervisor you can wait
for the supervisor but i'm going to go
through what i need to go through
are you are going to be assured
now i think it should be said
there are people
who if they treated a police officer
like this maybe not this police officer
this woman seems pretty good at keeping
her calm but there are other officers
who would have ripped the person out of
the car
if they had a different profile if they
weren't an older white guy we we must
admit that we must concede that not i'm
not i'm not saying this officer i'm not
saying this officer would treat
different people differently she might
be really good and she might be able to
stay calm no matter what there are other
people who if they did this
would have been ripped out of the car by
other officers well you've been already
issued a citation for that
for failing to produce your registration
all right sir are you gonna
an option to plead not guilty an option
to take a safe driver's course if you
qualify for the course it will reduce
your fine
and it will reduce your points if you
decide to go ahead what is he even
saying it's not even clear what he's
saying
with that just make sure you do a
private submission you don't want it you
know what he said about you
you want to hear what he said he could
say all he wants about me i got a job to
do sir you know what he said okay if he
fails completely
okay
and he's gonna have you again
and that's fine it's not five white
people sir i'm a law-abiding citizen
you've been bloody rude if you decide to
go ahead and do the four just make sure
you do a practice it's what what is he
even so pissed about he was going 57 and
a 40 and texting law abiding okay these
are civil infractions
at this point
uh he he broke
you know traffic law
man
submission of payment as they do
require a certificate you think you're
winning that's fundamentally what this
is about isn't it
oh man um let's see what the follow-up
was here
uh republican congressional candidate on
florida caught on tape threatening a
police officer's job he's running in the
florida 16th district was pulled over in
sarasota uh according to officer julie
beskin he was going 47 in a 57 and a 40
and texting
the body camera footage showed him
threatening the officer's job
um
hi how are you doing okay so we got that
i'll call the chief how's that she says
go ahead you know who i am right yes yes
okay
i want to see the aftermath
officer attempts to give him his russian
immigrant status called supervisor hands
over the registration
says the tenure might not last longer
it's not showing uh any any follow-up so
far
wow
what a prick huh what a prick this guy
is really just unbelievable unbelievable
um
just got online today so sorry to ask
david because you've probably covered it
could you clarify your latest opinion
every day i'm doing a clip on that
nicholas so i'm not i'm not going to do
it again right now but every day there's
a there's at least actually today it's
like three or four clips a day
um over on the uh
on the youtube channel
about about all of this stuff okay i
want to say thank you to paul lowther
who just signed up on my website with
the coupon code please don't war also
thank you to garrett merkin who just got
a twitch prime subscription and is
number 20 number
i invite you
to sign up on my website join pacman.com
it's the number one source of our
funding we have been streaming every day
this week guys every day there's been a
stream and it will continue we will be
live the next hold on
three days
with cpac starting tomorrow at 3 45 pm
eastern time and it is just a great day
i mean listen
if you've been waiting to sign up today
is the day to do it it really is let's
do a couple more voicemails i know that
we were just we were just getting into
the thick of it um here's another one
from our friend whitney
but i just felt like maybe italy didn't
like anything kind of like conflicting
with their privilege
and i don't know if kate middleton is
you know exactly like italian
um
but they seem to like appreciate like
the image more and like the superiority
disorder i don't know anything about
that back to troy york oh david pacman
i want to give you a
warning was at this barn and connect
illinois and
this guy who knows kyle renthouse i
guess he was talking about the parents
he had on
tucker carlson and
kyle rennhaus um
i was at steve starkson in maniac
and he was saying that um
kyle renhoff is going to sue a variety
of people and not just the mainstream
people
i don't know what he's saying and he's
eating food and it's it's it's just
bizarre it's i do wonder what is going
on in a lot of these people's lives you
know
so what's freaking out like really
freaking me out
um
is that right after the holocaust um
there was like a
a time when i wasn't here like i don't
know what happened or what the
demographics were yeah just check
history you should take a look at it
because i'm seeing like germany all the
way up north near like
uh
like i think
um
i think north dakota
near the canadian northern germany is
nowhere near near north dakota whitney i
hate to tell you i don't know if anybody
else has suggested checking a map but
northern germany is near south dakota
it's not near north dakota
hey david it's sarah from mass and i got
a message from hulk hogan what are you
going to do brother when hulkamania and
vaccine induced aids runs wild on you
there is no such thing as vaccine
induced aids in case anybody would be
confused i want to make sure to put that
on record so we don't have any
issue with the youtube or twitch uh
moderation and and etc kevin's saying
prosecutors in the trump crime probe
have resigned that just broke when i was
going live i haven't read about it yet
i'll cover it tomorrow
david have you seen greg abbott
instructing texas dcf to investigate
parents of transgender kids for child
abuse this is the real gazpacho police i
have not seen that story yet
uh david tell york that this war might
be worse than kyle rittenhouse
yes
absolutely i will tell them that is a
very very fair point i i don't know any
other way to say it
you know mr pakman
why is it that you don't
interview alex patterson from
media matters
about
what he has documented
about spotify as well as joe rogan
rather than author your personal apology
for him saying oh i think he's uh i
think he's sincere i think he's an
honest guy man i don't even know what
this guy's talking about
um avi says i wanted to send you 10
pounds but didn't have such currency
please accept french euros instead we
tend to have a policy on the show of
only accepting italian euros
but we on occasion we will accept uh
french euros
so i know like um
gay guys i
don't like
vaginas
oh man
i guess we should wrap up the stream
soon on that note that's
that's really something
uh
thanks to casey bates
for the twitch prime subscription
uh
man
i don't think i can do it anymore
that's gonna do it for today
we've gotten caught up on the news
i will be back tomorrow we've got a
podcast episode we'll have youtube clips
and i will be live with kimberly
guilfoyle's unhinged cpac speech
at 3 45 pm east
12 45 pm west
that's tomorrow
we'll see everybody then